foreign
[Music]
daily cancellation we must officially
cancel San Francisco State universities
you probably recall on Friday we
discussed the chaos that ensued at the
school when a former NCAA swimmer Riley
Gaines came to speak there gains have
been described by some media Outlets as
a conservative speaker but as far as I'm
aware she's never announced her
political views publicly at least I
don't think she has she may she may be
conservative she may not be all we know
is that she recognizes that men are men
women are women and uh she doesn't think
men should compete against women in
women's sports if this is a right-wing
belief these days and I suppose by
default it is it's only because the left
has entirely succumbed to Madness I mean
now if you recognize that the sky is
blue and two plus two equals four you're
automatically a far-right conservative
which is a situation that as an actual
far-right conservative myself I guess
I'm okay with because if the left wants
to give us exclusive ownership over uh
the most common sense and fact-based
observations you can make then I'll take
it I suppose
anyway gain spoke at uh San Francisco
State University on Thursday it wasn't
until after her talk that all hell
really broke loose a mob of enraged
frothing at the mouth trans activists
assaulted gains chased her down the
hallway forced to force her to barricade
herself in a room for her own safety and
uh just to review again if we didn't see
this video on Friday but here's what
that looked it sounded like
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
we remember that scene um as we saw on
Friday the the mobs stayed outside the
room for a long period of time refusing
to let her leave at one point someone
suggested forcing her to pay cash for
the right to leave safely this is
otherwise known as kidnapping uh the
crime that crime kidnapping can be added
to the charges of assault harassment
intimidation or at least that crime
would be added to the charges if there
were any charges being filed if either
the University or local law enforcement
cared to hold a rabid horde of trans
activists accountable but they don't
instead the next day a woman named
Jamila Moore who's the vice president
for student affairs and enrollment
management at the school she sent out an
email uh which which makes the mob into
both the heroes and the victims of this
story of course here's what you said
quote dear SF State Community today San
Francisco State finds itself again at
the center of a national discussion
regarding freedom of speech and
expression let me Begin by saying
clearly the trans Community is welcome
and belongs at San Francisco State
University further our community
fiercely believes in unity connection
care and compassion and we value
different ideas even when they're not
our own SF state is regularly noted as
one of the most diverse campuses in the
United States this is what makes us
great and this is what makes us this is
what makes us Gators and this is what
makes us great diversity promotes
critical discussions new understandings
and enriches the academic experience but
we may also find ourselves exposed to
Diversion views and even views we we
find personally abhorrent these
encounters have sometimes led to Discord
anger confrontation and fear we must
meet this moment and Unite with a shared
value of learning
this is already a load of nonsense of
course diversity does not in and of
itself promote critical discussions or
new understandings and neither does it
enrich the academic experience unless of
course a swarm of leftist zombies
chasing a woman down the hallway like a
scene from 28 Days Later counts as
enrichment
which in Jamila Moore's case or in her
mind it certainly does it's also what
she means by discussion and
understanding
specifically she wants people like Riley
Gaines to come to the understanding that
her views are heretical and unwelcome
and her life has no value so long as she
remains in her state of apostasy
continuing with the email it says
thank you to our students who
participated peacefully in Thursday
evening's event it took tremendous
bravery to stand in a challenging space
I'm proud of the moments where we
listened and asked insightful questions
I'm also proud of the moments when our
students demonstrated the value of free
speech and the right to protest
peacefully
yeah that's
chasing down the hallway screaming
that's not only protesting peacefully
but also demonstrating the value of free
speech
we're to come and assault you
and and try to rip you to shreds if you
say something we don't like because we
value free speech
sure
she continues these issues do not go
away and these values are very much at
our core this feels difficult because it
is difficult as you reflect process and
begin to heal please remember that there
are people resources and services
available and ready to receive our Gator
Community including faculty staff
members coaches and mentors who are here
to support you campus resources are also
available equity and Community inclusion
counseling and Psychological Services
the dean of students office the
well-being of the SF State Campus
Community remains our priority
now it's hard to know where to begin
um once again we see how the words our
violence crew doesn't believe that
actual violence is violence
or even that words are violence
depending on what the words are and who
they're being said to
you'd think that if any words could be
violence if words could ever qualify as
violence in and of themselves it would
be the words that are screamed at a
young woman by a slobbering throng of
lunatics as she tries to flee if afraid
for her life
except in that case words aren't
violence an actual physical assault
isn't violence either
she also applauds the uh the the mob for
their bravery because apparently it
requires bravery to a cost and harass a
woman who you outnumber like ten to one
or I don't know sorry 100 to one maybe
and she offers counseling services to
those who need to heal not for Riley
Gaines of course who was barricaded in a
room while a gang of trans militants
stood outside negotiating for her
surrender and demanding literal Ransom
payments
the school isn't worried about her
trauma
instead they're concerned about the
trauma inflicted on the mob itself
which is ridiculous of course but it's
not far it's not as far from The Mark as
we might think because the people in
that crowd they do need intense
psychological counseling just not for
the reasons that Jamila Moore would say
you know these people they they they
love to talk about Nuance you know we
always hear about Nuance we need to have
nuanced conversations to understand the
nuanced situations and this very nuanced
world we live in they say
but there could not be as we see time
and time again and again here there
could not be a less nuanced worldview
than this than modern leftism which is
what you saw in that video that's what
it is
to them it's all very simple very black
and white both literally in figuratively
because if you're if you are the enemy
and Riley Gaines qualifies as the enemy
then everything you do is wrong
everything you say is wrong
and there is nothing anyone anyone could
ever do to you
uh
or anything anyone anything anyone could
say to you that would be unjustified or
overboard in their mind
enemies do not deserve to speak
or to live in peace or to live at all
their well-being is not taken into
consideration
unless we're considering how to destroy
it that is
it really is as simple as that and San
Francisco State University could not be
clear about it in their response to this
incident this is how nearly every
University would view this situation by
the way
which is something to keep in mind
before enrolling in one of these places
or sending your kids there
it's also why San Francisco State
University is today canceled that I'll
do it for the show today or for this
part of the show anyways we'll go over
to the members block and become a member
today by using Code wall should check
out for two months free on all annual
plans hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]